blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
pour bien qu'on prenne soin que
demandent précisément l'europe à
l'europe de bande de choses c'est très
simple elle demande d'abord la
libération immédiate de monsieur rosacée
beach est également de madame sylvia sa
pizza c'est à dire les deux personnes
qui ont été arrêtées dimanche après midi
lorsque l'avion la ryanair a été obligé
de se poser à minsk au lieu de ceux de
se diriger comme sa route que prévoyait
vers vilnius
et puis une deuxième chose l'union
européenne demande aussi que qu'il y ait
une enquête internationale objective et
que toute la transparence soit faite sur
les conditions dans lesquelles cet
événement a pu se produire
alors d'abord je crois qu'il faut
remarquer que tout le monde a été
surpris et sans doute monsieur le cas de
chèques ou le premier de la rapidité
avec laquelle les 27 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement ont réagi
on est toujours l'union européenne est
divisée c'est vrai souvent mais là 24
heures après l'événement ces décisions
sont tombées avec des sanctions et les
sanctions se sont comme vous l'avez dit
dans le sujet d'une part que les
vingt-sept demandent à leurs compagnies
aériennes de ne pas survoler l'espace ne
pas survoler la biélorussie et puisque
c'est dangereux
avec ou sans des dissidents à
l'intérieur des avions et d'autre part à
titre de réciprocité
elle interdit son espace aérien l'espace
aérien de ses états membres aux avions
biélorusse et par conséquent les nos
aéroports sont interdits aux avions
biélorusse et puis les 27 chefs d'état
et de gouvernement on demandait aux
instances de l'union européenne de
réfléchir à des mesures d' à des
sanctions ciblées qui ne serait pas
supporté par la population mais qui
mettrait en cause
les dirigeants de ce pays qui ont
quelque chose à voir avec la décision
qui a été prise dimanche dernier
et puis enfin les instances compétentes
de l'union européenne vont être appelés
à allonger la liste des 88 personnes et
entités qui sont sanctionnés à savoir
qu'elles ne peuvent pas avoir de visa
pour venir dans l'union européenne
qu'elle ne peuvent pas détenir des
comptes bancaires ou avoir des avions ou
des avoirs financiers à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne
donc c'est un ensemble de sanctions
relativement modérée au bout du compte
qui ont été prises pour faire peser la
pression sur le président loukachenko
mais dans l'immédiat effectivement la
demande pressante c'est qu'ils libèrent
les deux personnes qui ont été arrêtées
dimanche soir alors justement après ce
vote des tournées à ce qu'on peut
imaginer une enquête internationale
digne de ce nom
il faut une enquête internationale et
d'ailleurs
la russie l'a souhaité monsieur lavrov
l'adie très dès dimanche soir et le
gouvernement biélorusse a déclaré qu'il
était prêt à accueillir des enquêteurs
internationaux et qu'il était prêt à
jouer la transparence
alors je crois qu'il faut mettre le
gouvernement biélorusse au pied du mur
et que l'oaci qui se réunit demain son
conseil se réunit demain à montréal
la russie a fait partie bien entendu
tous les pays en font partie eh bien on
décide dans quelles conditions on
déclenche immédiatement l'enquète en
envoyant des enquêteurs compétent sur
place sur biélorussie mais aussi sans
doute à athènes pour poser un certain
nombre de questions alors parmi les
questions à poser
il ya évidemment la liste des passagers
qui ont embarqué dans cet avion de
ryanair et qui a cette liste est bien
sans doute la compagnie ryanair mais
aussi l'aéroport d'athènes est aussi le
service des douanes et de la police des
frontières grecques
et puis de comparer cette liste avec la
liste des passagers qui ont atterri à
vilnius le point d
l'aboutissement de ce vol et on constate
comme tout le monde l'a dit l'aéroport
de vénus l'a fait le savoir que
effectivement il ya cinq personnes en
moins les deux qui ont été arrêtées et
trois autres personnes qui pour des
raisons qu'il appartiendra aux
enquêteurs de déterminer sont descendus
à minsk
alors qu'il n'y avait pas d' étape
prévue à minsk ça c'est un point qui
devra être éclaircies par l'enquêté puis
par ailleurs puisque les deux
le journaliste et sa compagne pour été
arrêté dimanche soir n'était pas en
vacances en réalité en grèce il était un
forum économique à delphes une sorte de
davos grecs auxquels se trouvait aussi
madame d'éthique à minsk aia c'est à
dire là qu'elle a la dissidente qui
s'était présenté au mois d'août dernier
contre monsieur loukachenko et qui
ensuite a pris la tête des
manifestations avant de se réfugier à
vilnius
elle était aussi à delphes à ceux à ce
colloque dans lequel elle devait faire
une communication à prendre la parole
compte tenu de ces éléments je suis
persuadé que la police grecque à des tas
d'informations sur ce qui s'est passé
pendant ce colloque est que les services
grecs sans doute aussi les services
biélorusse sava tas de choses sur ce qui
a pu se passer at-elle et il faut bien
que quelqu'un est informé le
gouvernement biélorusse de toute manière
des personnes qui étaient dans l'avion
et du fait que le journaliste dissident
était dans cet avion
donc cette enquête permettrait de
déterminer ces différents éléments et de
vérifier que les procédures utilisées
pour l'atterrissage forcé à minsk était
bien des procédures régulières prévu par
les traités internationaux
l'oaci est fait pour cela et il se peut
qu'il ait eu quelques entorses graves
aux traités internationaux
donc tout ça devra être éclairci et je
pense que l enquête le permettra on peut
douter
en fait c'est un peu le sens de votre
question peut être que monsieur le cas
de ces coûts se prête de bonne grâce à
cette enquête
on verra bien il faut le mettre au pied
du mur que les enquêteurs se présente et
qu'il décrive la manière dont ils sont
accueillis
et dont ils sont à même de faire cette
enquête
merci claude blanchemaison pour vos
précisions